all hail northwest the reigning queen of
tick-tock who just posted a classic
reaction video to a creator transforming
himself to look just like northey so
cool over the weekend kim kardashian's
eight-year-old daughter dueted this
video from tick-tock user matthew
perlman doodling over a selfie to turn
himself into north's twin
kind of do what i gotta say
matt who has animated himself to look
like olivia rodrigo on the cover of her
album sour jennifer lopez in that famous
versace dress at the 2000 grammy awards
versace i saw donatello with it and i
had to have it for the grammy
and ariana grande at the same awards
show in 2020 just to name a few posted
this clip inspired by northeast ensemble
for pajama day at school
well kim and kanye west's little girl
was mad impressed with his skills in
fact she was speechless
[Music]
and the sweet back and forth didn't stop
there matt shared north's reaction video
calling her his bestie in the caption
and matt he's channeled north's famous
mom too yep here he is as the reality
star in season one of keeping up with
the kardashians
[Music]
and that's matt as kim from the 2019 met
gala he even channeled north's aunts
kendall and kylie jenner from the same
event
i love that but back to north she and
her mom launched their joint tick tock
account in november
you know social media is such a great
tool and the two have delivered some
pretty legendary content ever since holy
spirit activate activate activate we're
going to in and out
[Music]
and despite what kim may have said in
the past i just don't dance okay i make
money moves right
she even busts a move
why not
of course this all comes after north
went live on tick-tock without her
parents permission
mom i'm live
okay bye
[Music]
having kids is just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot but it seems
all is forgiven since north is back on
the platform with her mom doing what
they do best giving fans the content
that they want
[Music]
[Music]
you